coragem é quando você enfrenta um
desafio na sua vida e você decide
avançar decidiu tomar um passo à frente
e superar esse desafio
você entende que você tem que avançar
para superar onde você quer chegar e
quando você faz com amor com o coração
da coragem
normalmente você consegue chegar lá pra
mim
um dos momentos que eu senti mais
coragem na vida foi no começo do atacado
no começo da onde que eu criei com
alguns amigos que tinha o intuito de
conectar voluntários com organizações
sociais
a gente queria criar um site em qualquer
pessoa que queira começar um trabalho
voluntário possa entrar no nosso site e
lá descobri uma vaga
de acordo com a sua causa só a
disponibilidade do seu tempo ea
localização então a gente queria
possibilitar que todas as pessoas
pudessem ser voluntários
o que a gente fez naquela época foi
visitar as ongs para contar o que a
gente queria fazer
agora o nosso site e a gente já visitava
elas compartilhando com elas quando
querem lançar o site datados
foi aí que aprendi a primeira lição
sobre coragem de falar para as pessoas
que a gente vai fazer alguma coisa
normalmente a gente consegue fazer
porque a gente já se comprometeu com as
pessoas que a gente falou que ia fazer
então o que eu vou fazer hoje já me
comprometi com algumas pessoas que eu
vou fazer isso e eu quero muito fazer
então vou fazer isso agora só que pra
mim não foi tão fácil e da coragem desde
o começo quando a gente começou à tarde
eu trabalhava no mercado financeiro e eu
tive que me demitido no trabalho pra
começar o atalho me focar exatamente
naquilo que eu queria fazer o que eu
sabia que tinha muito potencial eu sabia
que aquilo ia chegar longe e realmente
chegou a gente já conectou mais de 100
mil voluntários que começaram um
trabalho voluntário em alguma
organização social com mais de 1500 ongs
muitas histórias que a gente é muito
feliz de ter feito isso
só que pra mim como eu falei não é tão
fácil ser corajoso quando era criança eu
gostava muito de jogar tênis
só que eu jogava tênis com medo era uma
criança tímida eu jogava tênis para
fazer a bola passar e chegar outro lado
esperando que eu tocaria e rabiola meu
adversário errava e não para fazer um
ponto realmente ganhar dele
e foi num dia jogando tênis que
realmente mudou um pouco o meu jeito de
ver a vida um pouco meu jeito de ver a
coragem que eu sinto
foi um jogo de tênis em um campeonato
que eu fui com meu pai que eu joguei
tênis estava visível na minha cara o
medo que estava sentindo de errar a
próxima bola nesse torneio eu perdi o
jogo e depois meu pai me deu uma super
bronca e eu fiquei pensando que na
verdade aquele jogo de tênis refletir o
que estava fazendo na minha vida estava
sem muita coragem e sem muita vontade de
fazer aquilo que eu queria fazer e aí
fui eu fui repensando foi caindo algumas
fichas
o que eu percebi notados depois foi que
o trabalho voluntário que possibilita
você enfrentar suas garagens
quando você faz um trabalho voluntário
você sai da sua zona de conforto
você vai pra outro lugar conhecer novas
pessoas falar com outras outras
instituições outras realidades
e quando você está fazendo isso você tem
que tá de peito aberto de coração aberto
para uma nova experiência
quando você faz um trabalho voluntário
disse de peito aberto para essa
experiência você cria um campo de que
você ensina mas ao mesmo tempo você está
aprendendo e quando você faz isso você
toca na vida das pessoas
você começa a ver o potencial que essas
que essas pessoas também podem trazer
foi isso que eu vivi notado durante seis
anos que eu tenho feito muitos trabalhos
voluntários e foi isso que a gente
começou a refletir e que eu vejo outras
pessoas também que começaram o trabalho
voluntário e começar a empreender sua
vida começaram a ter mais coragem depois
uma vivência voluntária
então pra mim o que me inspira é motivar
as pessoas a se envolverem com uma ação
voluntária que eu sei que isso vai pedir
a ela
ao mesmo tempo ela vai causar um impacto
eu quero contar três histórias que me
inspiraram muito nesses tempos
a primeira história a história de um
casamento
dois idosos se conheceram em um asilo e
eles começaram a se aproximar e ficar
muito próximas a isabel e agenor
até que um dia a isabel chegou france
que a gestora dessa ong que trabalha com
idosos e falou pra mim que ela queria se
casar
a aliansce foi lá falar com agenor e
perguntar genoa que história é essa não
ainda vou pensar e aí isso aqui no filho
decidiu mesmo se casar ea gente era
muito amigo do irã se pela proximidade
que a gente tem razão isso ea gente viu
potencial nessa história a gente vê o
quanto a gente podia causar um impacto
nesse casamento se a gente trouxe muitos
voluntários para festejar junto com
esses idosos
então a gente chamou de jazz decoração
da festa pessoas que deram presentes
para os idosos que foram conversar com
os idosos que cuidaram da produção da
alimentação foi uma super festa de
casamento um dos melhores casamento que
eu já fui na vida e as pessoas
participaram no casamento depois viraram
voluntários também de forma recorrente
quero que a gente queria fazer
possibilitar que as pessoas fossem
voluntários e dali se encantassem com a
causa e continua assim o trabalho
voluntário no ano seguinte é a minha
segunda história eu comecei a entender
que inspira as pessoas para transformar
a fazer sentido que a gente iria
inspirar as pessoas para a causa dos
refugiados pessoas que vêm de outros
países da síria do congo e que começam
aqui no brasil uma nova empreitada de
vida mas que não têm muita rede e às
vezes não consegue um trabalho tão fácil
a gente queria levantar essa causa para
a população e até 2014 ano de copa aqui
no brasil
o dia mundial dos refugiados é cair no
meio da copa do mundo ea gente resolveu
fazer uma copa do mundo e dos refugiados
um campeonato de futebol que reuniu
times da síria do congo da costa do
marfim e de gana do haiti e da venezuela
e da colômbia para jogar futebol entre
si num campeonato de futebol só que para
celebrar e traz se conectar voluntários
com os refugiados brasileiros com os
refugiados
e foi isso que aconteceu no fim o haiti
que ganhou a copa só que a gente fica
tão feliz com a conexão que aconteceu
entre os brasileiros e os refugiados se
você perguntar para alguém que
participou da copa
qual foi a impressão dele ou se quem
ganhou a copa talvez ele não lembre mas
ele vai lembrar talvez um nome de uma
pessoa da copa de uma história de um
refugiado
e foi aí que a gente tem para a nossa
próxima história
algumas pessoas participaram desse
evento com os refugiados
falaram que o pessoal do congo pana
exemplo sabe falar francês o pessoal da
síria sabe falar inglês e árabe
o pessoal do haiti eles falam cinco
idiomas
eles falam francês e que eles
aprendem desde criança espanhol em
inglês que eles aprendem no colégio e
eles chegam no brasil e falam português
então eles sabem cinco idiomas e tem uma
cultura extensa gigantesca
só que eles não conseguem trabalho aqui
no brasil por uma falta de conexão com a
cultura do brasil ea gente decidiu
conectar esses idiomas esse conhecimento
com a vontade dos brasileiros de
aprender com os refugiados
a gente decidiu criar junto com muitos
voluntários uma escola de idiomas em
refugiados são os professores
a gente chamou voluntários de pedagogia
para ensinar os refugiados serem
professores e de comunicação para
comunicar-se da inovadora e quando a
gente lançou o curso de idiomas chama
braço cultural
quando a gente lançou o braço cultural
em abril uma turma de julho a gente teve
800 inscritos para essa turma ea gente
sabe que o negócio continue que ia dar
certo
hoje três anos depois a gente tem um
abraço cultural em são paulo no rio em
barcelona e em paris ea gente entrega só
aqui no brasil 40 refugiados ea gente já
gerou mais de dois milhões e renda para
refugiados aqui no brasil e fez algumas
pesquisas em que descobriu que o abraço
cultural é o maior empregador de
refugiados do brasil e eu comecei a
refletir sobre a minha vida sobre todos
esses nesses projetos que eu fiz e como
eu poderia levar isso para a minha vida
pessoal e profissional também em 2015 eu
decidi me mudar para o rio para começar
o atentado saque que tinha começado em
são paulo com outros três amigos e aqui
no rio foi uma aventura bem grande
eu vim pra cá em setembro com a vontade
de lançar o ataque do fla no dia 5 de
dezembro é o dia mundial dos voluntários
no dia 5 de dezembro três meses depois
que a gente chegou aqui a gente já tinha
70 ongs parceiras 30 voluntários
engajados e cinco pessoas na nossa
equipa a gente conseguiu lançar o
atacado já com mais de 100 vagas de
voluntariado aqui no rio
só em três meses pela conexão que a
gente fez com as ongs e pela coragem das
pessoas que estava junto com a gente
mundo abraçando a causa e acompanhando
essa empreitada que a gente estava aqui
eu pessoalmente ainda conseguiu um
apartamento para morar de graça aqui no
rio
tudo pelo extinto terá com o tema
coragem que eu tive de me aventurar
nessa aventura aqui no rio e sempre que
eu estava aqui é voltava para são paulo
há cinco semanas para me divertir pra
reconhecer meus amigos para me
reconectar com eles e foi no fim de
semana que foi para são paulo
me apaixonei pela fé sincera eu fiquei
com ela dois dias e depois de dez dias e
tive que voltar para o rio e voltei para
o rio mas eu ficava na cabeça como que
eu vou fazer para ficar com ela de novo
e aí eu decidi comprar uma passagem pra
ela pra dar de presente para ela me
visitar aqui no rio foi uma coragem que
eu tive no ímpeto
pode não parecer tão grande mas foi
coisa talvez mais importante pra gente
continuar juntos até hoje eu comprei a
passagem
ela veio pra cá para o rio e visitar e
depois de um tempo a gente começou a
namorar há uns meses depois eu fui para
são paulo a morar junto com ela a gente
decidiu morar junto de alguns meses
depois a gente viu que a gente já tem
uma filha que vai nascer daqui um mês
quem não sabe o nome dela mas a gente
vai descobrir aqui um mês
então eu a minha mensagem para vocês a
quando você estiver em um desafio e
vocês verão uma oportunidade mas com
carinho faz com amor que vai dar tudo
certo
obrigada
[Aplausos]